but it's like
you know I kind of miss watching TV and
feeling bad about myself and I feel like
Hollywood has taken this away from me
you know I used to open a magazine and I
would see women Megan Fox Angelina Jolie
and I would just leave
feeling a little bad I'm like damn I'll
never look like that but you know you
still appreciate the beauty you it's
like so you know I would go to a
basketball game or a volleyball game and
I would feel a little bad you know and I
really feel like Hollywood has taken
away the hierarchy of beauty we used to
reward the most beautiful people and
that was the standard to be in Hollywood
but for whatever reason
um I really just think Hollywood doesn't
want to appeal to the male gays anymore
they want to appeal to the female gays